[Musique]
on fait jouer en fait avec nous pour la
Coupe du monde et vous pouvez gagner un
panier Garnier juste avant les fêtes de
Noël il suffit juste de me donner en
fait les deux finalistes probables et le
vainqueur
on se début décembre c'est le sport à la
mode
même les moins passionnés par la Coupe
du Monde se laisse tenter par un
pronostic et ben je vais dire France -
Brésil
et le vainqueur la France
comme ça alors
Claudine France Brésil perdu cette
finale n'aura jamais lieu mais ce n'est
pas très grave au marché on joue pour le
plaisir
Stéphane ils ont pas forcément la notion
de Paris en tant que tel c'est plus un
pronostic justement on n'utilise pas le
terme Paris on préfère utiliser le terme
pronostic ce qui déjà enlève enlève
psychologiquement un premier frein
puisque quand on dit Paris effectivement
il est question généralement d'argent
alors que pour le côté pronostic c'est
plus un côté sympa familial en famille
mais la nuit tombée les enjeux sont bien
différents la France affronte la Pologne
une défaite et des minerais les Bleus
si tous regarde la télévision certains
clients jettent aussi un œil à leur
smartphone
j'ai travaillé sur sur du coup France
Pologne j'ai mis soit Griezmann ou bapet
butter et du coup j'ai fait un combiné
c'est à dire que j'ai ajouté un autre
pari pour augmenter ma cote on regarde
ce qu'on veut parier on clique on mise
et ouais ça dure 20 secondes vraiment
c'est hyper rapide
et surtout très accessible à cette table
d'amis presque tout sont une expérience
avec les paris sportifs
surtout sur la première ligue et ce que
je regardais que ça et du coup je
voulais faire des petits Paris et tout
ce qui passait et au final moi j'ai pas
mal gagné au début genre vraiment
pendant cinq six mois je crois que je
faisais que gagner et ensuite j'ai tout
reperdu les seules fois où j'ai parié
c'est quand avec des copains j'ai fait
confiance un peu trop et donc j'ai parié
sur des choses et au final j'ai perdu ça
m'a un peu vacciné du coup je parie pas
du tout sauf quand il y a des gros
matchs comme ça ça met un peu de ça met
un peu dangereux quoi
si à cette table on mise des petites
sommes à quelques mètres de là ces
parieurs jouent dans une autre division
j'ai misé sur le Maroc contre la
Belgique la côte était à 4,50 j'ai misé
200 euros puis j'ai pris 900 euros ça
risque à prendre aussi mais ça permet
d'arrondir les fins de mois je trouve
que c'est vraiment une bonne chose par
arrondir les fins de mois puis en tant
qu'étudiant c'est un peu que m'aider
ça fait 3 ans maintenant que je suis
enceinte maintenant je comment dire
quand je perds il m'arrive de
désinstaller l'application et quand je
sais qu'il y a un match malgré moi
mon épaule de gauche me dit de
réinstaller cette application
[Applaudissements]
encore raté 20 ou 200 euros peu importe
les sommes misés lorsqu’un pari est
gagné l'émotion est toujours présente
[Applaudissements]
donc là tu as eu le résultat que tu
souhaitais
si l'Angleterre gagne 3-0
cet engouement fait le bonheur des 17
opérateurs agréés en France nom du
buteur score à la mi-temps du foot au
billard quel que soit le sport et le
pays vous pouvez dépenser votre argent
comme vous le souhaitez sur tous les
terrains toutes les actions
aucun pari ne peut se faire sans méthode
un succès qui est porté par un marketing
agressif multidiffusé en 2021 les
dépenses publicitaires ont atteint le
montant record de 237 millions d'euros
grosse côte gros gain gros respect un
investissement qui paye car en 2017 les
joueurs actifs étaient près de 2
millions quatre ans plus tard la barre
des 4 millions est dépassés soit une
hausse de 124%
un résultat incroyable qui va de pair
avec des mises toujours plus importantes
lors des grands événements comme nous
l'explique l'autorité nationale des jeux
le régulateur des jeux de hasard pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée en 2018 en
mise on était à peu près à 366 millions
d'euros de mise avec une France
victorieuse
durant le retour qui s'est déroulé en
2021 on est monté à 435 millions d'euros
de mise actuellement sur le Mondial on
est sur des hypothèses plutôt hautes on
a eu 200 millions d'euros de mise sur la
première semaine de compétition avec un
calendrier qui était certes dense on
pense qu'on arrivera à peu près autour
de 500 520 millions d'euros
d'après la NJ le parieur type est un
homme
âgé entre 18 et 35 ans citadin amateur
de rap et qui mise en moyenne chaque
mois de 138 euros
et face à autant de parieurs un nouveau
métier a fait son apparition le
pronostiqueur professionnel du pain et
des jeux tel était la devise des
empereurs romains au temps des
gladiateurs gladiateurs qui se battait
dans le Colisée à Rome un mois après
l'ouverture de son compte Tik Tok en
novembre Maxime démiottes compte plus de
70 000 abonnés intéressés par ces
analyses sur des championnats exotiques
je vais
tous les joueurs étrangers ont été
transférés le club est relégable je vois
une victoire du changing Tigers
et voilà c'est dans la boîte donc là je
vais pouvoir la publier sur Tik Tok
c'est instituteur de 30 ans passionné de
foot est un pionnier des pronostics
depuis 2014 il partage gratuitement ses
analyses sur sa page Facebook pendant
une période il a travaillé avec certains
opérateurs
ça par exemple si à l'époque où je
faisais de la filiation pour Winamax et
là tu peux voir qu'en un seul mois je
m'étais fait 2100 euros donc je te
laisse imaginer ce que peuvent toucher
les pronostiqueurs professionnels
gagner de l'argent en proposant à son
audience de cliquer sur un lien
sponsorisé par un opérateur de paris
sportifs ce n'est pas interdit cependant
sur Internet les pronostiqueurs vont
beaucoup plus loin rejoignez-moi pour
cette coupe du monde je vous le promets
je suis persuadé cette coupe du monde
elle y a un doux elle est à nous j'ai
analysé déjà tous les matchs il y a des
sites internet ou sur les réseaux
sociaux certains n'hésitent pas à mon
nier des pronostics annoncés infaillible
contre un abonnement payant
tu es complètement interdit de vendre du
conseil en analyse sportive pourquoi
parce que les paris sportifs sont encore
considérés comme un jeu de hasard donc
c'est totalement interdit de vendre des
conseils en paris sportifs tous ceux qui
le font ils ne sont pas dans le cadre de
la loi qu'importe si sur leur site il y
a un numéro de siret si le site fait
professionnel etc c'est interdit et même
lorsque l'abonné est mal conseillé le
pronostiqueur peut encore gagner de
l'argent toutes les personnes qui vont
s'inscrire en passant par le lien du
pronostiqueur dès que ces personnes vont
perdre de l'argent sur le site de paris
sportifs et ben il y aura un certain
pourcentage qui ira tout droit dans les
poches du pronostiqueur et ceci à vie du
coup le pronostiqueur j'ai envie de dire
il est gagnant quoi qu'il arrive
[Musique]
je viens de perdre mon travail à cause
du jeu j'ai le sentiment d'être esclave
du jeu
je me retire définitivement des paris
sportifs c'est devenu une drogue
10 ans que je joue au Paris j'ai perdu
environ 140 000 euros
d'après santé publique France sur sans
parieur sportif une quinzaine risque de
basculer dans une pratique problématique
ça a été le cas de François ancien
addict pendant 12 ans il a accepté de
nous parler
faut vraiment différencier cette
addiction d'une autre et on prend la
cigarette on voit quelqu'un fumer dans
la rue voilà je sais pas il y a
quelqu'un il va dire je suis dépendant
je suis deux paquets par jour c'est
compliqué d'arrêter ok mais la personne
n'aura pas trop de mal à en parler
finalement parce que c'est visible alors
que les paris sportifs c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très intime les gens
seraient surpris de voir à quel point il
existe tout type de profil qui de
personnes qui sont addict au paris
sportifs
l'addiction aux jeux d'argent est
reconnue comme une maladie par l'OMS
aujourd'hui il existe des structures
spécialisées sur ces sujets
les signes ça va être déjà une perte de
contrôle c'est à dire qu'on va pas
réussir à s'arrêter malgré les pertes
on va observer une envie de se refaire
donc à chaque perte d'argent ça va être
je vais continuer encore et encore
jusqu'à récupérer gain et même quand il
y a un gain bah il y a cette idée de
pouvoir encore gagner plus donc c'est
vraiment un cercle vicieux une
préoccupation aussi pour le jeu qui
devient un centre d'intérêt principal
donc c'est comment ça se questionner
quand ça prend beaucoup de place quand
on se sent plus préoccupé qu'on va
délaisser des activités qu'on aimait par
le passé que c'est un impact sur le
travail
face à un loisir qui se transforme
parfois en pathologie 2022 marque un
tournant les campagnes de
sensibilisation se multiplient sur les
écrans l'idée de ces marketeurs c'est de
les faire rentrer dans ce cycle en fait
parier c'est pas rien si vous avez des
questions rendez-vous sur le site joueur
info service
et la prévention passe aussi par des
clips de rap destinés aux jeunes publics
devenir riche sur un hall je dégaine la
plier cette Givors dans le stade
poche pas de place en novembre les
opérateurs en ligne ont même du Signe et
une charte de bonne conduite afin
d'éviter des publicités comme celle-ci
voir un jeune d'une vingtaine d'années
manifestement d'un milieu social plutôt
modeste qui grâce à un pari sportif
offre à sa maman tout à fait une
nouvelle vie avec l'allégorie de
l'ascenseur donc on la voit monter dans
les différents étages qui symbolisent un
peu les étages de la sensation sociale
un plus on monte plus c'est luxueux
seconde degré ou publicité mensongère
lundi a tranché et a interdit ce spot
évidemment faire croire à des personnes
qu'avec du paris sportif ils vont
pouvoir changer de vie mettre leurs
parents à l'abri résoudre toute leur
difficulté financières c'est quelque
chose qui est totalement faux et
d'autant plus faux que c'est pas vrai
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui les
parieurs sportifs qui gagnent plus de
10000 euros par an la proportion elle
est presque à zéro
les opérateurs de paris en ligne ont
aussi l'obligation légale de ne pas
s'adresser aux mineurs pourtant un tiers
d'entre eux a déjà joué à des jeux de
hasard en ligne ou dans un bar PMU
interrogé les buralistes assurent au
moindre doute car ils sont surveillés de
près par La Française des jeux pour
contrôler les points de vente d'Orléans
ils vont par exemple ils peuvent même
embaucher un mineur pour nous contrôler
et que pour faire jouer mineur par
exemple pour voir si on va fournir un
jeu quelconque au mieux ça arrive même
très souvent très souvent même encore
plus maintenant donc le jeu est hyper
contrôlé en France
et pourtant impossible d'empêcher les
plus déterminés de valider leur grille
faut qu'on regardait les compositions
tout ça avant les joueurs qui jouent
ceux qui jouent pas c'est mieux comme ça
il y a plus de chance de gagner à 19 ans
ce jeune homme a déjà une longue
expérience des jeux d'argent
je commence à parler très jeune je
commence à parler vers 14 ans 14 ans je
commence à déjà passer mes premiers
tickets c'était quoi comme ticket comme
Paris que du foot que du foot je joue
que depuis que je suis petit je joue que
au parifoot
que tu as été imminent on t'a jamais dit
non non pas toi etc
plusieurs
mais plusieurs tabacs il me refusait il
me disait carte d'identité tout ça il
voyait que j'étais mineur bah je vous ai
dit la technique c'est quoi c'est juste
d'envoyer un monsieur par exemple le
monsieur à celui-là moi si j'aurais été
mineur j'aurais dit entre m'acheter mes
clopes passe-moi mon pari en même temps
il aurait pas trouvé de ça le dérange
pas ça le dérange pas il le rentre il le
fait pour directement
chez les 15-17 ans 12% sont considérés
comme joueur problématique selon une
étude de l'autorité nationale des jeux
cette année face à l'addiction 46 000
volontaires se sont faites interdire de
jeux
[Musique]